bonsoir olivier python merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france
quelle est votre réaction à la vue de
ces images est ce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à ce climat d'extrême tension
et à ces événements qui se déroulent
aujourd'hui au coeur même de la
démocratie américaine
alors on pouvait à la fois être
extrêmement surpris par la violence des
deux ce qui est en train de se passer en
ce moment tout en ayant malheureusement
le sentiment que c'était absolument
inéluctable ça faisait quand même
plusieurs mois plusieurs semaines en
fait depuis le 3 novembre que donald
trump et ses partisans en refusant le
résultat final du 5 novembre et est dans
une espèce de logique de confrontation
totale
maintenant pour la première fois depuis
deux cent quarante quatre ans on va
envoyer la garde nationale pour libérer
le capitole ça n'est jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire des états unis dit ça quand
même
c'est un événement absolument incroyable
olivier python j'insiste justement sur
ce côté pouvait-on s'y attendre parce
qu'on entendait tout à l'heure le
journaliste gérald olivier nous dira
finalement ses programmes pour ne les a
pas écoutés on les a même méprisé dans
les médias américains
quand on voit aujourd'hui le résultat on
prend la mesure de cette colère tout
simplement
du camp pro trappe d'abord on les a
surtout sous-estimé il est incroyable
pour qui connaît washington qui est une
ville extrêmement sécurisé en
particulier les lieux de pouvoir que des
centaines de personnes et puis p ait pu
pénétrer dans le capitole et puis
pénétrer dans la chambre des
représentants ils sont en train
d'essayer de pénétrer au sénat c'est
absolument incroyable
donc on les a clairement sous-estimé
maintenant pour répondre clairement à
votre question oui effectivement il ya
une fracture évidente entre deux
amériques y qui nous n'en sommes plus au
stade où elles ne se parlent plus elles
se détestent et elle se combattent
elle se combattent elle se combattaient
par les mots là on est passé à une phase
supérieure qui est une confrontation
physique
on espère tous que les appels au calme
envoyez d'un peu partout va permettre de
faire baisser la tension
mais si vous voulez il faut bien
comprendre que on est à un point de
paroxysme de fusion entre deux amériques
qui on arrive à se haïr littéralement
qui ne se parlaient plus depuis
longtemps et qui aujourd'hui sont au
banc de la confrontation
alors effectivement on apprend à
l'instant en tout cas c'est une
information qui nous est parvenu par le
new york times inquiète plutôt réputé
pour être un journal sérieux canonge en
explosifs avaient été découverts au
siège du comité national républicain
cette fois de de washington samedi quoi
justement ça 17 extrême climat de
tension qu'on sous-estimé presse aux
presque 7 et est ce que vous nous
expliquer écouter ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui c'est en fait le la
l'explosion du parti républicain mike
pence qui est en tant que vice président
des états unis
le président du sénat en exercice a
envoyé une lettre et a fait un discours
en expliquant qu'il ne soutenait pas la
démarche de donald trump qui consistait
à remettre en cause les résultats des
élections et donc la volonté des pros
trump de pénétrer non pas simplement au
capitole mais haas au sein du capitole
qui est à la fois la chambre des
représentants et le sénat dans un même
grand bâtiment
cette volonté d'entrer dans le sénat est
une manière
de punir les républicains et en
particulier mike pence d'avoir trahi
donald trump et donc on a une fracture
énorme au sein du parti républicain
entre on va dire les loyalistes qui
souhaite que l'on soit fidèle ou à la
constitution et que donc on ne fasse pas
un coup d'état
et puis on va les appeler les trolls
beast qui eux sont prêts absolument à
tous parce qu'il considère que la
victoire leur a été volé alors
effectivement donald trump qui s'est
exprimé à 17 heures heure française qui
a peut-être mis on écoutera votre
analyse mais de son côté aussi le feu
aux poudres
donald trump qui a dit qu'il ne
conserverait jamais la défaite c'est
assez étonnant effectivement peut-être
inédit dans l'histoire américaine
il a fait un appel solennel à mike pence
dans son discours en disant nous
attendons j'attends de mike pence qu'ils
fassent ce qu'il doit faire c'est à dire
refusé de signer la ratification par les
membres du congrès de la victoire de joe
biden et ont comme je vous le disais my
peines a refusé donc il y a il y a eu
une logique jusqu'auboutiste de donald
trump qui ont plus subi la mauvaise
nouvelle
des résultats des deux sénatoriales ans
en géorgie on pourra peut-être en
reparler aussi parce que je pense que ça
a contribué aussi au climat
et là il a fait deux appels extrêmement
tardif a demandé à ce que cessent les
violences mais d'abord ses tweets arrive
bien tard parce que les programmes sont
déjà dans la place et surtout ils ne
sont plus contrôlable c'est à dire qu'on
est maintenant une situation où
finalement il échappe littéralement à
donald trump et on ne sait pas du tout
comment la situation peut évoluer
olivier piétons justement ces programmes
qui se sentent parfois bafouée comme
j'ai enjolivé nous l'expliqué comme vous
nous l'avez dit est sous-estimé surtout
est ce que ce n'est pas un résultat
contre productif qui va se passer
finalement retenir ce genre d'image
extrêmement choquant
est ce que ce n'est pas un passif
justement pour le président sortante
oui c'est un énorme passif parce que ce
qui restera de la présidence dans de la
présidence trump dans l'histoire ce sont
les images qu'on est en train de voir en
ce moment et que vous montrez c'est à
dire qu'on n'efface quatre années qui
sont beaucoup plus contrasté entre des
aspects politiques qui sont positives
d'autres qui le sont moins de la
présidence trump là on est sur deux
l'émotionnel pur on est sur un quasi
putsch quasi coup d'état on a quand même
le centre du pouvoir aux etats-unis le
vrai centre du pouvoir c'est le
parlement beaucoup plus que le président
le centre du pouvoir est pris par des
manifestants c'est la première fois que
ça arrive ça n'était jamais arrivé ni au
cours de la guerre de sécession
il n'y a aucun moment dans l'histoire
depuis deux cent quarante quatre ans et
c'est ça qu'on va retenir alors ce que
deviendra le tropisme pour répondre à
votre question et ben à partir de ces
images
il va être profondément d'évaluer
dévalorisé et sans doute qu'aucun
républicain qui voudra se présenter dans
les années qui viennent ne pourra
honnêtement se référer à 7 à cette
période parce qu'elle est elle est
monstrueusement honteuse pour les
américains et quand je dis le mans
honteux c'est le mot qui revient le plus
dans les tweets des de n'importe qui aux
etats-unis que ce soient des
responsables politiques ou de simples
citoyens qui s'exprime c'est la honte
pour eux c'est clairement la remet ça
n'est jamais arrivé
vous parlez d'un coup d'état et ce avec
afp nous rapporte des propos de
manifestants anonyme nous reprenons la
chambre c'est notre parlement ça veut
dire quoi que ces manifestants
finalement ils se sentent floués par une
élection on leur aurait volé c'est en
tout cas ce qu'ils ressentent
si vous voulez ce qui se passe c'est que
ville départ il y a eu un débat
dès le 3 novembre dès le 4 novembre il
ya eu un débat sur les fameux vote par
correspondance et sur le fait et on
pouvait s'y attendre que au début du
dépouillement donald trump et est en
tête en particulier dans les états dans
les swing states
et puis vous sommet au fur et à mesure
joe biden a refait son retard pour
finalement l'emporter
et donc il ya une énorme frustration qui
est lié au fait que si vous voulez vous
avez des gens qui ont le sentiment
d'avoir été volés c'est le principe de
l'élection qui a kiss et qui s'est
étendue sur trois mois et non pas sur un
jour comme ça se passe d'habitude en
démocratie on vote le matin ça se
termine le soir sauf quelques cas
particuliers pour les votes par
correspondance et puis c'est tout là on
est un vote qui s'est étalée sur trois
mois où les résultats au compte gouttes
sont tombées en donnant d'abandonner le
tram va coeur et ensuite jobin donc la
frustration de cet électorat de cette
partie de l'amérique est énorme
et quand et quand donald trump depuis
des semaines dit nous avons été volés
il s'appuie justement sur ce sentiment
vous voyez c'est ça qui rend les choses
particulièrement difficile olivier
python on apprend à l'instant que joe
biden prend la parole on dirait qu tu es
la télévision joe biden qui appellent
clairement donald trump apprend deux
sites à la parole pour défendre la
constitution des états unis et honorer
le serment qu'il a fait est ce que ce
serait peut-être la meilleure attitude à
adopter pour donald trump que d'accéder
à la demande du président élu joe biden
oui vous avez raison de valve trump a
tweeté deux fois pour demander la pelle
il a fait deux appels à ce qu'on cesse
les violences mais il n'a pas été au
delà
d'autres se sont exprimés beaucoup plus
de manière beaucoup plus véhémente
mais si vous voulez le petit pas à
franchir du côté donald trump dans dix
ans on arrête tout je reconnais que on
est allé trop loin et c'est fini ce
petit geste là ce petit mot là ce petit
pas là il ne le fait pas et comme il est
face à des supporters qui à mon avis pas
mon avis seulement mais elle a vite
beaucoup sont maintenant hors de
contrôle y compris par donald trump lui
même est bien de toute façon on est dans
une situation qui pour l'instant est
hors de contrôle complètement hors de
contrôle et de toute façon donald trump
n'a pas fait le petit pas que joe biden
va lui demander de bien lui demander de
faire est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
justement à ce qu'il le fasse dans les
prochaines minutes
est ce que yahoo oui est ce que c'est
dans son intérêt finalement de laisser
ça revient la conversation tout à
l'heure mais de laisser faire de l'est
s'est montré cette image justement
peut-être de quelqu'un qui n'accepte pas
la défaite en tout cas pour ses
opposants
je sais qui c'est son intérêt c'est
difficile de répondre à cette question
surtout avec ce qui se passe en ce
moment en revanche puisque c'est dans ce
tempérament il a toujours montré depuis
le début que ça ne l'était pas qu'il
n'était pas dans cette logique là qu'ils
étaient toujours dans la logique du
jusqu'au boutisme et il n'y a pas de
raison qu'ils changent alors il fait un
appel au calme mais ça ne va pas au delà
pour l'instant ce dire qu'il le comme on
le disait il ne franchit pas le petit
pas qui serait celui finalement de
l'acceptation des résultats pour le bien
du pays pour la constitution pour ce que
l'on veut histoire de mettre fin à cette
situation il n'en est pas là et donc son
tempérament c'est toujours le même c'est
celui de du refus de la défaite on
appelle au calme mais pour autant on
refuse de reconnaître la défaite
olivier py temps quand on voit ces
images dans les était certainement des
miliaires
effet ce temps on va dire cette colline
du capitole à washington
quelle est la proportion de ces pros
trump voilà aussi trop tram j'ai envie
de vous dire on imagine quand même qui a
une division au sein du camp républicain
aujourd'hui est ce que pour autant on
est pro trump mais on approuve ce type
de manifestants où il ya vraiment cet
état d'esprit qui est campé aujourd'hui
chez les partisans de donald trump
voilà je crois qu'il va y avoir une
vraie césure parce que les américains
les images ils sont tout à fait
conscients que ces images sont montré au
monde entier en particulier aux russes
et aux chinois
d'où le terme de honte qui revenait
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
à partir de là il y à une césure parce
que une partie des républicains ne peut
pas accepter ces images est ce que l'on
voit ce cx que l'on voit ici ce sont les
jusqu'au boutistes
ce sont ceux qui n'ont rien à perdre et
qui sont dans une logique de pour le
coup vraiment de coup d'état
en revanche la grande majorité je le
pense vraiment dû du camp des
républicains va se désolidariser de
cette de cette situation et d'une
certaine manière c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure c'est la grande défaite
de donald trump
c'est que l'on ne retient on est en
train de ne retenir de lui que ses dix
matches là donc le split la division du
parti républicain est une évidence
aujourd'hui parce que ils ne peuvent pas
soutenir ces images ça n'est qu'une
poignée de jusqu'au boutistes qui qui
qui soutiennent ces images ce qui ne
veut pas dire que la grande majorité des
républicains comme les sondages l'ont
montré à de nombreuses reprises ne
continue pas à penser que donald trump
s'est fait voler sa victoire mais il ya
une différence entre cela et allait
quasiment orchestré un coup d'état au
capitole alors vous le disiez des images
qui sont montrés dans le monde entier à
l'instant
boris johnson le premier ministre
britannique réagit londres dénonce des
scènes honteuse
il ya quelques minutes déjà yann
sundberg
le patron de l'otan a dénoncé des scènes
choquantes et a demandé à ce qu'on
respecte les résultats de la
présidentielle
il y aura des conséquences à ces
événements aux etats unis aujourd'hui
les conséquences internationales
c'est difficile de savoir quelles seront
les conséquences internationales à très
court terme en tout cas moyen et long
terme c'est une énorme gifle pour le
leadership américain pour la gêne pour
la nation morale la nation qui a quand
même tendance à c'est souvent là donner
des leçons au reste du monde et de
leçons de démocratie en particulier
c'est une terrible gifle c'est une c'est
absolument terrifiant en revanche les
les conséquences en interne et en
particulier le suivi pénal parce qu'il y
aura un suivi pénale
il ne peut y avoir qu'un suivi pénale
après ce qui est en train de se passer
là en revanche on peut aller très loin
on peut même aller jusqu'à un nouvel
hymne pitch mount vis-à-vis de donald
trump comme ça a été demandé par un
certain nombre d'élus démocrates
merci en tout cas olivier python a en
direct de washington avocat à washington
de nous avoir apporté votre
d'observateurs votre analyse de ces
événements